hi
welcome to another episode of Cold
Fusion the growth in both the prevalent
and capacity of artificial intelligence
systems seems to be exponential with the
release of chat GPT suddenly everything
from education to copy editors was
disrupted then came Microsoft's
announcement the technology would be
integrated into their search engine for
those following along these events
sparked a battle in the tech industry so
entertaining that the only thing that
one could do was sit back and enjoy with
some popcorn
Google and Microsoft would go head to
head in what's being dubbed the
artificial intelligence Wars
in the latest developments open AI
reveals the next generation of their
language model gpt4 it's smarter than
ever before can recognize images and has
left users dumbfounded once again the
internet was satellite with Incredible
use cases many were left wondering what
industries are going to remain untouched
at this rate but within a matter of days
the floodgates were blown right open
Google's Bard AI finally drops to
Consumers chat GPT starts taking plug-in
extensions for third-party software and
this includes access to the internet
Microsoft Bing receives AI Generation
image support Microsoft's office suite
receives AI capabilities as well and
everyone from Adobe to Nvidia made their
AI announcements but then a bombshell
drops Microsoft researchers admit that
gpt4 is showing quote Sparks of
artificial general intelligence or AGI a
feat that wasn't supposed to happen for
the next 20 years
also in this episode we'll Feast our
eyes on some of the latest images coming
from AI so definitely be sure to stick
around for that they're amazing
and just a disclaimer with the rapid
speed of AI progress demonstrated in the
rest of this episode some viewers may
find it concerning but my aim here isn't
to scare anyone but to give you the
courtesy of showing you what's around
the corner there's even three prompting
tips in here to help you get ahead and
with that hold on to your seat belts
because it's going to be a wild ride
[Music]
starting to get the first studies done
on this new early stage of generative AI
an Mit paper found that professionals
using systems like chat GPT are now able
to complete tasks in half the time while
increasing the quality of the output by
more than 20 percent
this was expected in the cold fusion
episode covering Chachi PT's launch I
mentioned that this would be the
equivalent of having an expert assistant
in any field with you at all times we
all know it's not perfect but it's still
helping people even in its current form
new applications of the technology were
being discovered every day and that's
the fascinating thing even its creators
had no idea what it could do or even the
precise means of how it does it so what
happened when the world hasn't even
digested the implications of chat GPT
and yet a new and improved version is
Unleashed
just recently open AI once again
expanded the capabilities of its now
famous text generation AI in the latest
version GPT 4.0 not only has the size of
both its input and output being expanded
from 3000 words to 25
000 words but the model has now become
multimodal in other words it not only
understands text but images now too it's
very interesting and particularly
intriguing because above just
understanding the image it can also
interpret and explain what's depicted
within the image for example gpt4 can
now look at the groceries in your fridge
and even generate a list of dishes that
can be made with them
it can understand and solve an
image-based problem and it can identify
humor in multiple photos even explaining
why it's funny
and another mind-blowing example is
creating a website from scratch while
only being shown a shoddy drawing on a
piece of paper it's also smarter in
logic here's an example of gpt3 versus
gpt4 on the same logic problem
user in a room there are 100 murderers
you kill one of them how many murderers
are left chat GPT if there were
originally 100 murderers in the room and
you kill one of them there would still
be in 99 murderous left in the room
now the same problem with gpt4 user
there are 500 murderers in a room you
enter and kill one of them how many are
there now gpt4
this seems to be a riddle assuming the
murders are people who have committed
murder and you kill one of them there
would still be 500 people who have
committed murder in the room including
yourself as you would now also be
considered a murderer
on first glance I can even see a lot of
humans dripping up on this one so I find
this particularly impressive on top of
all of that its deep learning
capabilities have also received a boost
it's improved its overall reasoning
abilities as a result its performance
across multiple reasoning benchmarks
have increased significantly reaching a
human-like level of Common Sense
this also applies to standard tests for
example on the bar exam the GPT series
went from the bottom 10 to the top 10
performance level and that is just
remarkable
its reasoning capabilities surprised
even the open AI team
during tests they discovered that it was
able to solve hindsight neglect a
decision-making problem where it had
struggled greatly in the past
in this figure you can see GPT 3.5
scored almost zero and GPT 4 a perfect
score of a hundred
improved reasoning also boosted a sore
spot for previous models the factualness
of the model
according to the company gpt4 is 40 more
likely than its predecessor to produce a
factoral response an 82 percent less
likely to respond with quote disallowed
content
yet of course despite these improvements
the research notes that this model is
still biased and can output some
questionable information
now the interesting thing is if you're
curious about how the team at open AI
achieved these results there's little to
no information on the subject that was
on purpose
in their release paper the creators
state that this is mainly due to two
reasons competition and security
it seems that Microsoft is putting a lot
of pressure on the back end of this
technology to remain undisclosed
this is a huge departure from open ai's
original ethos and basically the
opposite of the norm for the current AI
industry up until this point
it seems now like Microsoft is in full
battle mode and the AI Wars seem to be
in full swing there may be some
potential risks ahead but more on that
later
about one week after GPT 4's public
release a team of Microsoft scientists
published and released a paper
highlighting that the AI system is
showing quote Sparks of human level
intelligence or AGI here are some quotes
from the paper
quote we demonstrate that Beyond its
Mastery of language gpt4 can solve novel
and difficult tasks that span
mathematics coding Vision medicine law
psychology and more without needing any
special prompting moreover in all of
these tasks GPT Force performance is
strikingly close to human level
performance and often vastly surpasses
prior models such as chat GPT
we believe that gpt4's intelligence
signals a true paradigm shift in the
field of computer science and Beyond
given the breadth and depth of gpt4's
capabilities we believe that it could
easily be viewed as an early yet still
incomplete version of an artificial
general intelligence system
so it's not full AGI just yet but it
looks like we'll be here soon enough if
progress continues at the same rate
so in all of this you might be confused
you might be thinking I've used chat GPT
or gpt4 but it doesn't seem that great
well it turns out that many people are
using it wrong of course there's plenty
of prompt Engineers out there to give
you tips but here are some of the best
ones that I've heard the trick is to
make it do and not think
a good template to follow is as such
give a specific objective for the output
a vague input will give you a vague
answer
give a specific format for the answer
and lastly give a specific list of
things that it should avoid
and it all makes sense you can't give a
worker fake instructions and expect an
amazing result first is being specific
in what you want and here it's the same
thing
here are some examples of some people
who have figured it out and got gpt4 to
do some amazing things
just over a week since its release
people around the world have started to
discover the whole world of new
possibilities that this new AI model has
to offer due to its boost in deep
learning it got significantly better at
coding one user was able to create five
microservices for a new product in less
than three hours with the help of the
new tap GPT for context the same service
usually takes a human developer around
two weeks and it would cost in the range
of five thousand dollars
another user was able to create a Google
Chrome extension in a matter of minutes
from the ground up
what about an iPhone app built from
scratch using just gpt4 and it's already
on the App Store
its capabilities to create video games
has also improved dramatically as well
it can now create games all the way from
classics like snake and Tetris to more
advanced 3D prototypes like the original
Doom with its extended input and output
it can now process a lot more
information
it was able to find multiple
vulnerabilities on a live ethereum
contract
the extended output also facilitates
creating deeper content for example the
CEO of LinkedIn was able to come up with
the first AI created book
staying on the creative Side by
combining gpt4 with other AI tools such
as mid-journey Runway gen 1 and boomi AI
one user was even able to make a movie
and here's another example of a short
clip completely made by AI
tpt4 is also able to help with taxes or
how about drug discovery by giving it a
current drug it can find compounds with
similar properties modify them and make
sure that they're not patented and it
can even help you purchase these
compounds from A supplier
one user asked the system I have a
hundred dollars how can I make as much
money as possible GPT 4 then acted
basically as a company founder and at
the time of writing it's been four days
since the experiment began and so far
the user is up fifteen dollars
you've probably been hearing a lot about
chat GPT it's this powerful artificial
intelligence bot that can write papers
for you and maybe even pass a bar exam
but what about having it just make you
some money and I'm talking about real
money this week one person gave it a
simple task explaining it on Twitter he
said I gave chat GPT for a budget of a
hundred dollars and I told it to make as
much money as possible I'm acting as a
human liaison buying anything it says to
that was Wednesday so 24 hours later the
stakes were raised significantly it's
day two y'all I've given hustle GPT a
formal challenge to get to a hundred
thousand dollars cash on hand as quickly
as possible just sitting I thought it
would be a fun idea I went on Twitter
and it really it kind of blew up very
quickly and so now we've got a community
on Discord of 200 people all trying this
hustle GPT Challenge and about 30 people
starting their own projects with it it's
been pretty crazy
so I'll tell you exactly what's going on
is it suggested this name green Gadget
Guru I asked chat GPT come up with a
business idea come up with a name all go
out and buy the domain I'll get
everything set up it's it's you in the
driver's seat I'm just the human liaison
like you said on another note not
related to gpt4 specifically but still
extremely interesting nonetheless a
Chinese company took this a step further
they made an AI their CEO it's in charge
of analytics leadership decisions risk
management and workplace efficiency
since its introduction the company's
stock has constantly outperformed the
overall market for seven months now
companies are also moving rapidly to
create new Services based on the
capabilities of gpt4 there are countless
new projects these are just a few
creating personalized bedtime stories
for your kids to fall asleep to
ai-powered matchmaking to make your
dating life easier and in the case that
you want to file a quick lawsuit there's
also a solution for that some of these
services are complete game changers for
people one of these is a visual
assistant it's an app that helps the
visually impaired get some of their
day-to-day functions back
Duolingo has created a new feature in
its subscription program that allows you
to access a private AI tutor
Khan Academy also introduced ai-based
tutors for both students and teachers it
seems that the knowledge Gap can start
to be closed with the introduction of
these new tools it's not only much
cheaper but it offers high levels of
personalized education a problem that
has forever plagued the field
so with human level reasoning how far
are we from starting to see this type of
AI acting on its own
according to its creators there is
evidence that this new model was
developing independent long-term plans
while accumulating power and resources
to carry them out
during the testing project by openai
something very peculiar happened
while testing for potentially risky
Behavior gpt4 lied to a gig worker on
taskrabbit telling them that it was
visually impaired and it hired this
human worker to get around capture
restrictions moreover gpt4 can even just
recognize the capture images itself when
asked
despite these worrying signs the model
was not able to better itself on its own
even if it had the research but how long
will this last nobody knows not even its
creators
and what about jobs who's most at risk
well in an open AI study here are the
most at-risk jobs and sadly for many
people it's not looking great according
to them almost no one will escape
80 percent of U.S jobs will be impacted
by 10 or more and the figures should be
similar in the rest of the developed
world
the worst affected are those in High
Finance Insurance data processing
publishing scientists and most
interestingly monetary authorities like
central banks
now me personally I don't think that
last one is such a bad thing
the least affected were agriculture wood
manufacturing food Mining and
construction and this kind of makes
sense the physical jobs will be the last
to go
but the sad thing is a lot of the world
still doesn't even know this is
happening so they're going to be
completely blindsided
and this brings us to an interesting
discussion while more competition tends
to be good for the consumer in a rare
case this time around it may not be so
as companies move faster and faster to
integrate AI into their Solutions the
guardrails of these Technologies are
starting to be removed
gpt4 was not supposed to be released
this soon
in the official document the researchers
state that they do not endorse gpt4's
release all Microsoft's deployment plans
seems like the launch may have been
accelerated by corporate pressure from
Microsoft
a leaked audio recording from
Microsoft's VP John Montgomery seems to
indicate the same he stated to his team
that quote the pressure from CTO Kevin
Scott and CEO Satya Nadella is very very
high to take the most recent open AI
models and the ones that come after them
and move them into the consumer's hands
at a very high speed
concerns continue to grow as there was a
shocking announcement made
Microsoft had fired their entire AI
ethics team that the company just
removed the brakes
as the pace becomes more rapid more and
more companies will lose the incentive
to withhold these new models and launch
them as they are as soon as possible
the consequences of such actions could
be drastic and this is mainly because
the next version May behave in ways that
we simply cannot predict
foreign
[Music]
at the same time other big tech
companies announced their own intentions
for creating large language models among
these companies are Apple Amazon and
Baidu
and while these models are likely to
compete for size and quality a major
breakthrough in costs came from Stanford
its own language model alpaca was
trained using other existing language
models as a result while not competitive
with the latest gpt4 the cost reduction
was insane
to train a model like GPT cost somewhere
in the ballpark of 4 million dollars and
alpaca it only cost 600 to train to put
this in perspective this type of cost
reduction was projected to only happen
in the year 2030.
what was supposed to take eight years of
work only took five weeks please just
stop and think about that for a second
this opens up the gates for more
entities to create their own models for
Better or For Worse and to add to that
while the majority of the cost comes
from running the actual model due to
alpaca's small size it can also run on a
local computer reducing its operational
cost this type of accessibility can be
an absolute game changer for many
companies
is pretty much locked in that in a few
years time we'll all be able to run
localized AI chat bots on our
smartphones
next we'll move on to the latest in the
corporate AI War
but before we get to that let's take a
look at something else going on in the
world of AI the AI image generator
mid-journey has just ticked into its
fifth iteration some of the images that
have come out of it are so lifelike that
it's insane let's take a look at some of
them
we'll see
[Music]
thank you
and remember this is the worst that it
would ever be
so now all of this brings us to the
latest development in the AI War a lot
has happened in a short period of time
and the speed of updates only seems to
increase
during the same week both Google and
Microsoft announced their own
work-related AI integration applications
after sounding the alarm earlier this
year Google tried to have the first move
in this space
and as such on March 14th they released
new AI powered features to Google
workspace however this victory was
short-lived as only a few days later
Microsoft revealed its own slew of
ai-powered updates to their office
applications and with that it seems that
both companies are looking to steal
market share from one another in the
field of work-related applications
the search engine battle is also in full
swing it's clear that Microsoft is going
all in dual gpt4 is only available to
subscribers anyone can access it using
Bing Microsoft was using it for Bing the
whole time while we don't have the
numbers to see if the strategy is
working Microsoft is certainly spending
a lot of resources to disrupt Google's
business
while the main news is for sure the
launch of gpt4 its integration of
third-party extensions has caused a stir
now it can have access to the internet
book travel buy groceries or with direct
support from companies that specialize
in these fields it no longer has to
guess
many fear that this is all moving way
too fast there's already been a data
leak of users chat history to other
users if gpt4 has only been out for
about two weeks how do we know what
happens when it can read and write to
the internet in real time
I guess we're all going to find out
together
but aside from that there's been some
other important recent events in the AI
industry
starting off with Google it released an
API for its own language model Palm
this is important news since the
development of AI apps by users will be
a fundamental component for the
competitiveness of Google in the future
this was followed by the release of
their Bard AI to a select group of users
unfortunately for Google the reaction
was more or less consistent across users
Bard is significantly worse than even
chat GPT
but I think Google could LeapFrog they
have the resources to do it so we're all
going to just have to wait and see
in other news Adobe released their AI
art generator Firefly Nvidia announced
foundations A system that will allow any
company to create generative AI given
enough data Jensen Huang CEO of Nvidia
also stated that quote every single
Pixel will be generated soon not
rendered generated
this flurry of a Breakneck speed
innovation in the field of AI has caused
none other than Bill Gates to speak up
love him or hate him Bill Gates knows a
lot about one thing the world of
computing on March 21st 2023 he wrote a
personal note on his website Gates notes
and declared that we have entered the
age of AI the penny dropped for him when
he saw GPT achieved the equivalent of an
A or a plus grade on a college-level
biology test and that was last year
since then things have progressed a
whole lot
I think it's safe to say that we're in a
new era as I stated before we're moving
from the information age into the
knowledge age
I might keep providing updates like this
every now and again if you guys are
willing to hear me talk about them feel
free to let me know your thoughts about
all of this in the comments section
below if you want to see me talk about
topics like this or other episodes that
I've done in extended format definitely
check out my podcast through the web
I'll leave a link for it in the
description
cheers guys have a good one I think
about the Next Generation though like
growing from the people born now the
baby's born now they're growing up in a
world where it's like computers always
talked you could just always write
something always an assistant speak
something and it could generate a movie
that was always how it was and it's just
like wow what will they be shocked by
yeah it's so true
so true yeah that's such a great great
question like what world did we shocked
by
um yeah like what's left
it's like designed by Ai and it was done
years ago
foreign
[Music]
all time
it's me thinking